a yoke of John drama my baby brother
finally gets his own movie this is very
exciting but [ __ ] all you for not liking
the movie going into this film I was
pretty excited I absolutely love the
series even though the last two seasons
weren't that greatly received I still
like what they did and I was really
happy with the way the show concluded
which kind of puts me in a weird
predicament as a big fan of the show I
have my issues when comparing the movie
and the television show but this other
part of my brain is being like don't be
that kind of guy just review it as a
standalone film yet a lot of the
solutions to the film's problems I felt
were in the show for starters I didn't
like the setup of this movie too much if
you guys haven't seen the show I'm sorry
but it's gonna get spoiled for you right
now it's been off the air for 8 years
what the [ __ ] are you doing at the end
of the series Vinnie chase is finally
settling down Ari Gold quits his job and
makes a full-time commitment to his wife
and kids the cat and mouse game of sloan
& e getting back together breaking up
finally ends with them getting together
but then the first couple minutes of
this film it starts off nine days later
and they literally just canned all of
that storyline so there was almost no
meaning to the show ending Ari's now
working as one of the studio heads with
his wife which I found really out of
character seemed to have no problem with
this and once again I'm sick of seeing
this but once again II and Sloan are not
together because Doug Ellin can't seem
to find a storyline where the two of
them being together is strong and of
course Vinnie's marriage has ended but
out of all of those problems I feel like
the one with Vincent chase makes the
most sense since he barely knew the girl
as far as this film goes I honestly feel
like that if you've never seen entourage
or you're not a fan of the show that you
probably won't like this movie like I
love the show so I really just enjoy
seeing these characters again the whole
ensemble the entourage plus re they
really know
these characters evening they played
them for years so when they're
interacting it's completely natural but
like a lot of television shows that
continued by doing a movie it does
suffer from that feeling of this is just
an extended episode or this is a
two-hour piece where they clearly
crammed a season in 22 hours so even
though they have my complaints and I do
have more complaints coming I do want to
establish I do like this film like at
the end of the day if i were to binge
watch the entourage series i would still
end it with this movie however its
dynamics and feelings are not really
that strong in this movie I mean from
what yes it does feel like an extended
episode and that's hard for these kinds
of movies to break because that's the
usual complaint about these kinds of
films I really felt like this movie
didn't do much more with its story to
make it feel like a big screen
adaptation this easily could have been a
two hour special on HBO like the show
had two main elements hanging out with
these dudes in LA partying smoking weed
getting [ __ ] lots of [ __ ] they still
get [ __ ] in this book there's there's
plenty of [ __ ] to go around in LA but
then the other side was dealing with
stresses in the pressure of like
assembling movie projects and trying to
like maintain career success and with
this story they chose for this film to
make all these elements work this story
would need a full season like i like i
said earlier it's like feels like a
season come packed into a film or i
could have just used a more solid script
when they got five main characters so
there's five different storylines and
since this film is an in samba they're
trying to do each character justice but
it sort of felt like that the
writer-director creator doug ellin had
this huge story but then had to just
take scenes from this story and put it
into instruction so in this movie at
times and if you're a fan of the show a
lot of the time it does feel like you're
just hanging out with these guys omid
sometimes it's kind of slow sometimes
it's a little dull but a lot of it's
great the movie studio drama works the
stuff that Artie's dealing with works
but I remember watching the show and
feeling like a little on the edge of my
seat and having feelings of oh [ __ ] I
never really got that in this movie I
don't love to hear your feedback if you
saw the movie on one
about thought about Max I feel like the
film's biggest problem was the way it
was captured if you pay attention to the
show it works so well because of the way
it shot and edited it's handheld editing
is faster paced there's more cuts it
feels more authentic that's why the two
main elements of entourage worked so
well because they got the privilege of
making this a movie they really amped up
the cinematography of this fellow so the
way it was shot looked prettier yet I
felt like it worked against it it took
away that natural hang out body like
it's cinematically shop and the camera
is really smooth the takes tend to go on
longer rather than like the faster pace
cuts that the show had the film does
look good but in terms of keeping the
same type of tone because that's what
the script was doing it actually works
against it you needed that same type of
camera style and editing like because
the way it shot you can tell that
certain scenes feel very rehearsed and
that it really feels like people are
hitting their cues especially the longer
takes no little trickery of handheld is
to make it feel more real and like more
involved so with a script that feels
like it's a buddy hangout movie that
takes its time it can feel kind of slow
alright and I've covered my problems
with this film hopefully you stayed till
this part cuz there are things that are
undeniably great Jeremy Piven as our
Eagle Lloyd he's once again the best
actor of this in Samba [ __ ] awesome
Jew he's a scene stealer he's hilarious
and like a lot of people throughout the
show you find yourself more invested in
him than anyone in the entourage I give
me crying during the last episode he's
an amazing actor and if there's a small
list of my entourage is adapted into the
big screen the number one thing on my
list would be seeing Jeremy pivens
portrayal of re goal on the big screen
like I said earlier the gang is back
they know these characters inside out it
was great seeing them all again and
although I didn't find the studio drama
stuff that intense I did like where they
went with the next step in Vinnie chases
career I like seeing the stresses and
the portrayals of being studio head and
an actor deciding to direct his first
feature film the way they concluded
dramas storyline in this film I truly
loved it was like the best way to do
it's the last scene before the credits
start rolling and it was fantastic
it was one of the few reasons why this
story he had a continuation was to add
to drama story because I was a little
dissatisfied with the way his story
ended on the show that is so yeah what
this show have been better as a full
season absolutely however if you're a
fan of the show like myself the love and
nostalgia is still present and you're
likely to walk away satisfied that's
what my girlfriend Nevers is but if
you're not a fan of show and this is
your introduction yep probably won't
like it let me get straight to the point
here all in all i gotta say entourage
got its built-in fan base right alright
guys thanks for checking out my review
for entourage you can go ahead and
follow us on facebook instagram and
twitter and last but not least if you
want to get updated every time one of my
reviews or videos is out going to clear
this but about my dick to subscribe
that's right the dick let me tell you
something about this little celebrity
every time he rolls into a woman's
vagina he brings his extra three members
of the entourage two balls and penis
that's what i was referring to in case
you didn't get it punchline